première étape mardi fixer le cadre
technique temps alloué aux présentations
en accusation puis de la défense trois
journées dès 8 heures pour chaque camp
durée des questions posées ensuite par
les sénateurs 16h et surtout témoins
cités à comparaître ou non une donnée
essentielle pour les démocrates qui
souhaitent interroger quatre proches
conseillers de donald trump ce qui leur
avait déjà été refusé auparavant lors de
l'enquêté
et c'est encore une fin de non recevoir
avec 47 sénateurs démocrates contre 53
républicain l'accusation avait peu de
chances d'obtenir gain de cause
deuxième jour c'est donc le camp
démocrate qui ouvre un bal chorégraphié
dons issus en faveur du contrainte ne
fait pas de doute
premier des deux chefs d'accusation abus
de pouvoir dans l'affairé craignait un
coup de téléphone entre le président
américain et son homologue ukrainien
donald trump est accusé d'avoir fait
pression kiev enquête sur le fils de joe
biden son potentiel adversaire démocrate
à la présidentielle dans la balance
notamment une aide militaire crucial des
etats-unis à l'ukraine voisine
le président entrera bloqué des
centaines de millions de dollars une
aide militaire à un partenaire
stratégique en guerre contre la russie
tu veux obtenir une aide étrangère lors
de sa réélection des joueurs d'action
hainard en d'autres termes pour tricher
et ne souhaite pas de cette façon le
président a utilisé les pouvoirs
officiels de l'état disposait et qui
n'était qu'un opposant politique pour se
donner un avantage lors d'un scrutin
eskemo zone ratage m a été entrepris
pour la raison simple mais perverse de
l'aider à se faire réélire en 2020 pas
mais ce stratagème pour effet de
fragiliser nos élections libres et
équitables et de mettre en danger notre
sécurité nationale
cet élu au total se succèdent ensuite à
la tribune dans le rôle de procureur
trois jours pour évoquer la fer
ukrainienne dans un premier temps
quatrième jour second chef d'accusation
entrave au travail du congrès en cause
justement l'absence des témoins dans ce
dossier ukrainien d'anciens membres de
l'administration trump qui ont refusé de
comparaître comme mike pence ou mike
pompéo les démocrates exigent
aussi des documents clés ce que leur
refusent aussi la présidence depuis le
début de l enquête
la conclusion de l'accusation est sans
appel trump est un dictateur une menace
pour la démocratie
you know vous savez vous ne pouvez pas
faire confiance à ce président pour
faire ce qui est bien pour ce pays mais
vous pouvez lui faire confiance pour
qu'il fasse ce qui est bon pour donald
trump
il va le faire maintenant
il l'a déjà fait il le fera pendant le
prochain mois
il le fera aux élections s'il y est
autorisée c'est pourquoi si vous le
déclarer coupable il devra être renvoyée
parce que le droit compte et la vérité
compte sinon nous sommes perdus les
défenseurs républicain de donald trump
souhaitait un procès rapide sans
nouvelles auditions ni élément
susceptible de nourrir l'accusation
après trois heures samedi ils auront de
nouveau la parole lundi
côté démocrate on sait depuis le départ
que ce combat est perdu d'avancé
la destitution de donald trump n'est pas
envisagée l'objectif des accusateurs
empêcher la réélection de trump à la
prochaine présidentielle
[Musique]